[Music]
foreign
welcome to the true Geordie podcast done
uh for those who don't know uh you have
a YouTube channel and one of the things
that you specialize in uh is talking
about uh the prison time that you had
and in particular in Romanian prison of
course yes yeah I think was five and a
half years you spent in prison around
five and a half years yeah ironically
you just so happened to be in the same
prison that it looks like Andrew Tate
might end up in if he does get convicted
yes so you've been through that whole
process that he's going through right
now I'll start off with what the outside
uh world are saying about this Romanian
justice system a lot of people you know
are wondering what it'll be like for him
is it corrupt can he can he just pay his
way out of this situation Andrew Tate
himself said I'm going there because the
laws are relaxed he doesn't know what
he's talking about there is corruption
as long as you talk about a regular guy
like me because no judge in Romania
would risk will take so much risk to let
him go away free if he's guilty or to
put him in prison if he is innocent
everyone should know this no judge on
Earth in this situation we talk about
Andrew take
the whole planet knows him now no judge
will take this risk because the whole
world is watching what they are going to
do
so I don't believe a judge will take a
bad decision a wrong decision sorry
we've seen he's been given a 30-day
extension of his arrest why would they
have done that
because it was a chance that he could
run away or he could write the the
weaknesses he has a lot of money he
could pay how much you want one million
take one million for example so it might
be the chance that the case could be
interrupted because of that not because
he's a dangerous guy for the society
um in terms of what he's been accused of
what is the attitude in Romania like
towards
um people who do human trafficking and
that that sort of thing because is it a
relaxed attitude or do people take it
seriously over there when we talk about
him there are two parts half of them
they are said yeah he's innocent Matrix
did it and the others aside it's like
man you think you're if you only if you
rich you can come in our poor country
and you can do what you want you're
gonna pay because even if we are corrupt
corruption is everywhere if you came
here and you make it so public what you
do and you make it so public that our
authorities are corrupted and you can do
what you want you're going to go to
prison no matter how much money you are
you have and no matter how much uh Fame
you got because what people don't
understand our judges no matter how
corrupt they are they put in prison a
lot of Romanian guys with way more money
than he had trust me I don't want to
give my name because I didn't ask for
the permission and I have respect for
okay Romanian people but trust me I can
give you 10 examples of rich people Rich
politicians corrupt politicians who got
in in prison
with way more money than entertain him
okay so this corruption thing is so
relative you know it's
so we've been talking about you know you
mentioned before the Matrix and how he
predicted that this would happen why do
you think he predicted that it's a
common fact on on the people who break
the law to blame the system
is not a system I was stupid enough to
break the law now I'm blaming that
system no I'm glad they put me in prison
so I can change my opinion
about making illegal money so do you
think they've got evidence
come with the first house warrant they
took all his recordings all his cameras
and he knew
they have evidence but he's he's very
intelligent but in a very evil way
because he's capable in manipulating the
people look
no matter what they gonna show you it's
all fake because metrics can do what
they want they can even fake a video I'm
undertaked listen to me we have an
invisible enemy
he wants me to shut up he don't they
don't want me to tell you the truth man
in the next next second
we both have an enemy who is this enemy
I don't know he can they can this defend
himself no because it's Matrix who is
Matrix we don't know
so you only hear my opinion my only my
side of the story exactly like in this
case we only heard what he said
but trust me the next second you're
gonna see a girl cry looking at the
camera and saying yes this guy raped me
and he slapped me so hard I have a lot
of wounds and uh he put me to do all
this stuff in the very next second a lot
of people will wake up until then okay
he created
a very uh he had a very big impact on
people because he has a style in telling
the truth that you want to hear that's
how he manipulates people he tell you
the truth that you want to hear but he
all all that he does he uses weak people
in order to win he's teaching us how to
be a man
I'm going to teach you how to be a man
how can you teach me how to be a man
when you're not many not to earn your
own money you need a weak uh vulnerable
depressed girl to make money for you
how can you teach me how to be a man I'm
man enough to earn my own money not so
much money I don't care but I work hard
for my money
man I get emotional I'm sorry man amen
I respect what you're saying and uh to
me um sitting on your ass while girls
take their clothes off and make you
money is uh that's not a real man's
earning there's been a video released in
the last 24 to 48 hours now done by
vice.com where they had a girl who
originally in the UK in 2015 had accused
him of rape uh and physical abuse and
she just as you've said predicted there
she's crying and she's saying what he
did I I didn't see that yeah so she
she's in a lot of distress on the video
you can't see her face and this is from
before he even got famous this was this
happened in 2015 but the police over
here they didn't act fast enough and by
the time it came to hand the case over
to the prosecution four years had gone
by and they basically did not have
enough evidence even though they had
eyewitness to the rape the alleged rep
so you're seeing that starting to come
out now in the UK and obviously then he
took his business over to Romania are
you of the belief just out of interest
that he is guilty when I was in prison I
met a lot of girl boys a lot of guys who
made businesses like this okay and I can
tell you one thing
uh I don't know how good looking guy
these these brothers are because I don't
don't know how to say about a man if
he's good looking or not but I know he's
not so good looking to in to convince 10
girls to work for him and to pay him
everything from what they earn man
you can make a woman love you maybe too
to love you enough and to make video
chat for you and to give you all her
money
but nothing man
who are you so the likelihood of him
telling the truth here
let's take his side one second okay all
the girls wanted to make video chat they
come they work at one point you have to
make uh to act
better with one girl and to act and to
act worse with another girl because
there will always be all kinds of
especially between womans if you keep 10
women in one room it will be world war
three so it's a very difficult after
some time you have to you have to be a
little bit aggressive so they can have
fear we people are like this
we we obey only if we are afraid of
something or of somebody I will be
afraid of you if I knew you are able or
capable to kill me I will not say a bad
word about you man I don't want to talk
about him who knows he's crazy he's
gonna kill me I just give you an example
to understand okay we are all like this
you you made a point earlier about
you've encountered men who set up
similar businesses in terms of
men who are rapists and I'm assuming you
may have come across some of them in the
prison system
what do you think it is that makes a man
do that when you can find a woman who
wants to have sex with you why is it
that they from the ones you've met what
do you think is the component in them
the Willing of power because
after some time especially for for the
rich people not for all of them I'm not
putting all in the same here yeah but
for for some of them it's it's boring
after a while yeah she wants to sleep
with me she wants to sleep with me it's
like in Christmas you have all kinds of
cookies here take this one take this one
no man and when Christmas is over and
you don't have any cookies anymore you
want to eat all of them exactly like
this is with money you have so much
money you have so much girls it's not
interesting anymore to sleep with one
girl or two girls or ten girls
but it will be very interesting very a
lot of adrenaline when I try to sleep
with a girl and she rejected me
or even if she wants to sleep with me
I'm aggressive enough that she will say
okay stop it until here
I like you I want to make love with you
but not like this don't eat me don't
slap me and from that point
he he's in power he's in charge you have
control of her life it's exactly like a
cereal creamer criminal thing because I
met a lot of Serial criminals also I I'm
not saying that Andrew thing is a Serial
criminal but but they all go on under
the same mentality
man my English I know it sucks but I'm
trying I'm doing good thank you you're
doing good yeah you I can understand you
no problem and in terms of where he is
right now he he hasn't been convicted of
anything yet he's being held what will
those
um conditioned circumstances be like
what kind of place will he be in right
now he is in Bucharest into in the
Central police station he is allowed to
give 10 calls a day 60 Minutes every day
okay and in terms of um how many
prisoners to a room and that sort of
thing
he's alone with his brother in the room
there are four people arrest two womans
and uh and Tate's brothers The Taste
brothers are in the same room alone and
the other two girls also in another room
alone
I heard that the prosecutor who's
controlling the case
I heard that that prosecutor is quite
well known in Romania for being very
good and taking big time gangsters what
have you heard anything about the
prosecutor what they've said what they
have what evidence they might have
anything like that yeah first of all
this prosecutor is very correct
so he's very he he have surveillance and
bodyguards 24 hours a day every day
because he brought a lot of influential
people in prison with money and fame and
political connection he don't care if
you're guilty you go to prison if you're
innocent he will give his life so you
can be free when I was doing bad stuff I
was afraid of guys like him
but now I'm happy we have uh prosecutors
like that in Romania has this prosecutor
said anything publicly in regards to
evidence or given any information out in
the media in Romania uh he only said
that the evidence that they got were
enough
for them to put him in a rest
so he is very sure he's guilty wow uh
one more thing maybe I don't know if you
know it or not we have six girls
one from USA one from moldavin and four
from Romania when was the first house
warrant was the first time coming they
found a girl the girl from USA in a room
locked up
yeah so they took the girl out they go
to police station and she said all the
story and she talked about the other
girls the girls were not allowed to talk
to each other
and listen to me
when they took all other five girls they
all had the same story how can you
explain there are clear evidence right
now because the stenograms of their
conversation are public now I don't know
if you know it yesterday they put police
put out some new evidence oh really well
so what what does that mean with
conversation between 1008 and
his guys and between Andrew Tate and the
girls and from their conversation you
can clearly see the girls were not
allowed to go outside alone only with
somebody always you know but not all the
time only when it was very necessary
they were not allowed to to talk to each
other some of the girls didn't even know
they gonna come to to make video chat
but like I said I put myself also in
Andrew Tate shoes and I will say okay
they all knew they're gonna make video
chat but still not under these
conditions okay I work for you but
you're not allowed to close me in one
room and
forget about me they they made a lot of
pressure to the girls to work hard and
hard and many hours because when you
make video chat you have to stay a lot
of hours to bring customers into that
private chat because on the private chat
they pay a lot of money a lot of the
customers wants to meet the girls so
they manage I I'm sure because they all
do this they also made a connection
between the clients and the girls they
brought the clients to the girls because
this is how the money is made
you know only only from video chat
there's not so much money how much money
did he said he earned from video chat
because I have I have friends who have
video chats they have also voice for for
gay chat they have also couples
because gays and couples earn way more
money than the girls
in video chat business just to let you
know I wanna know how much money he said
he earned from video chat I mean he said
in the hundreds of thousands a month
when he had all these girls but his
story changes so rapidly and the numbers
that he says in every interview are very
different so it's hard to know but from
from what my research told me just like
what you've just said the real money
the the the the the introduction is the
webcam but the real money is in the
actual prostitution the real meetups
where the guys come and meet the girls
and then have sex with them that's where
the real money seems to be in that
industry I don't know if Tate did that
but that's what I understand what you've
just said yeah my research is also the
same and I I had Direct contact with
people who own
video chat business the two women who
are arrested with them one of them was
ex Romanian and police officer what do
you know about this woman and what role
she played man I'm ashamed to talk about
her because I'm so disappointed when I
see such a thing you know a police
officer who goes on the other side man
you know that make me be afraid on
walking on the street man she was the
one
hitting the girls the most
so if a girl was reacting yeah I don't
want to work for you anymore if you all
of you
she will be the one who will go in her
room and kick her ass because obviously
being a police officer you have training
you're used to dealing with people
you're used to keeping order how did you
hear that by the way about that she was
the enforcer
from the from the uh how you call it
from the conversation they put out
yesterday all right okay I heard his his
lawyer was very cautious in what they
said in terms of giving statements
um yes also the lawyer
also the lawyer let's let's because I I
analyze everybody because I have this
style of analyzing people
um and I I analyzed the lawyer also he
was not so convincing that
normally a lawyer would come up with him
and they will say
don't worry he's innocent we're gonna
approve his innocence everything they
have is a BS but he was like uh yeah I
talked with the Tates Brothers they are
quite
relaxed we hope everything is going to
be fine we don't know yet he was so
insecure I was like [__] they really
have something again the rumor is uh
from what I understand anyway 10 to 20
years is what this charge carries given
the celebrity status of Andrew
um if he does not plead guilty which I
think a guilty plea would obviously get
that reduced I would imagine how do you
think that uh prosecution would handle
Andrew given his celebrity status if you
still find him guilty
if his charge from 10 to 20 they will
give him 15. even if he will say he's
innocent even if he will not cooperate
why because if if they will give him the
maximum punishment everyone will say
Matrix did it they will give him the
minimum sentence everyone will scream
entertain pay them it's a corrupt
country you have to understand no matter
what decision the judge will take
unfortunately the whole world will hate
us and this is so unfair
and man just
believe me
we are not such a corrupt country you
find corruption in every country also in
UK and USA everywhere I'm at let's
suppose he is found guilty and ends up
in the same prison that you went to uh I
really want to try and get an idea of
what those conditions were like in terms
of uh starting with
um How the Gods imprisoners will treat
him first of all normally they should be
sent to an accommodation room where are
50 people in one room 50 not 15. is that
with bedrooms or like is it just one big
room with a load of beds there is one
big room with a lot of beds wow okay bed
one bed two bed three all right if
you're strong enough when they all know
you you sleep on a first bed if you
still strong enough but you don't have
so much power in that prison you sleep
with the second bed
if you are nobody
or just a guy with the money you're
still gonna end up on the third bed
after 30 days you go in a normal cell
where are four people in the room or six
people in the room in this scenario
where he's in a Cell uh obviously he'll
be in there with other prisoners and
you'll have the prison guards given he's
a celebrity but also his charges would
be against him doing crimes against
women
how would his treatment from other
people be he has the right to go
on a protected area they will send him
in a protected area 100
especially that he make it public he say
it publicly uh they're gonna kill me
they're gonna put me in prison and
they're gonna kill me because he knew
with the charge of rape you can die in
prison he knew but the system will
protect him way more than a normal uh
inmate so the system will protect him
very much just so he cannot be killed in
prison and the whole world to say yeah
entertain
is a hero
you know what I mean and the system
killed him okay brought him to silence
how violent are Romanian prisons like in
terms of how often did you say violence
when you were in there and also like
what is the level the scale in terms of
what was the worst violence that you
witnessed with another guy that you've
seen happen 85
they mind their own business but like in
every prison in every County 15 maybe
are people who doesn't want to come out
who doesn't want to be
to to be you know normal again they want
to to have a criminal life that they
make a lot of uh bad things Andrew is
obviously a wealthy guy and he's used to
a very nice lifestyle lovely beds lovely
food
everything's been luxurious what kind of
like living is it going to be in terms
of the beds and the food and and whatnot
you know all have to understand
something in prison the worst enemy you
got are not the other inmates and are
not the conditions the worst enemy in
prison are your own emotions you miss
your family you miss your freedom man
I used to close my eyes sitting in the
bed laying in the bed closing my eyes
and imagining that I take a walk in a
park and saying hello to people Hi how
are you
I find things
and man after that opening my eyes and
man I'm still here man that is the worst
enemy you got in prison not the other
inmates I don't give I don't give a damn
if I have to fight 10 people I don't
care this is not the worst case the
worst case is when for example my my dad
passed away and they didn't let me go to
his funeral now that can kill you the
worst enemy you got is yourself because
you can kill yourself
you can kill yourself self I saw a lot
of guys big like you
who kills himself and I saw a lot of
guys like me
who managed to to survive and to go out
and to have a normal life again do you
think that that could be a hindrance to
him that he is used to such a happy life
so he's a pleasure Seeker we know he
loves pleasure and in jail there is no
pleasure do you think that that that
that that extreme change could really
hurt his mental health it's very
depressing yeah it was for me and I'm an
average guy I really a normal guy on him
and I can't afford to go in expensive
restaurants and for me was very hot very
hard to see all these words because of
the the world in prison your color
scheme changes men sometimes it changes
forever
you can see also in my face you see I I
have some problems because because of
the prison words it depends on how long
you stay there can you give me an idea
of like the average day of food in there
just to see what what people would eat
there they serve cabbage they serve
potatoes potato soup
cabbage wheat potatoes bacon
it was soup bowl soup a man and then all
over again rice but you don't want to
try that rice
the the the rice runs runs away from you
from your table and it's uh it's not
good okay in terms of like uh uh
cleanliness you know how some places
cockroaches and is it is it quite
irritating in terms of insects and
whatnot yeah
uh
I brought him out of man I forgot about
the insects I want to put I want to
forget about the insects men man now I
don't want to make a horror movie here
but uh there are a lot of insects man
what about um showering and exercise
because uh Andrew obviously loved
staying active looked after himself
always nice moisturized skin Andrew
tablespoon look what what kind of uh you
know how often will you allow to
exercise and how often can he shower and
stuff like that if he will behave
um
decent if he will respect the the laws
inside the prison he will be allowed to
go on the gym one one day in a week
one day showers two times a week
um
Tuesday and Friday
Tuesday and Friday two times a week it's
enough yeah that's mad that you're not
allowed to shower more than twice a week
that's it's expensive man yeah it's
expensive for them on the hot water
bills going up yeah with all those dudes
we prefer to invest in hospitals and in
prisons good yeah I think that's a good
idea I'm really learning a lot about
this and um he's bringing a lot of
attention and and a lot of negative
attention now to Romania
man he have this skill of manipulating
people
he's using weak vulnerable depressed
people in order to make himself more
Millions because I only have a question
if you want to help me and you want to
give me a good life advice
why should I have to pay 50 bucks for
your course because you're
multi-millionaire is it for free man
because I'm poor I want my money to to
be more Rich than you have ever been I
will never serve a course but I will
write a book about how to be a human
being I don't know how to write a book
about how to be rich I I've never been
rich but I believe we all need to to to
read the book on how to be a human being
because we seems to we seem to forget
how to be a human being we all try to
take advantage of each other
because you've really been honest and I
really appreciate it in terms of you've
watched cases play out several times
over the years and you've seen as you
say a powerful and famous people going
to prison in Romania if you had a
predict and guess roughly how this plays
out now what do you expect Andrew to uh
go through and how where does this end
up it's so difficult to predict because
on one way
I just want him to be innocent and I
just hope all the girls are lying
because I don't want to imagine those
girls suffering okay I just prefer the
option where uh all the girls are lying
but it's very difficult because only two
of them wants money from him the other
four girls don't want any money the
prosecutor said
that's why they took his house and his
cars because he ever
how you call it uh
[Music]
I will call it woman
sensation for what they've been through
yes yeah
so if the victims win uh and Andrew Tate
will leave the country they will have
something to sell and to pay to the
victims but only two of the victims
wants money from him the other four
wants no money
they just want him to pay for what he
does that's why it's very hard for me to
believe
it's all a setup because four of the
girls don't want any money they just
want Justice
if he is really guilty and they will
find him guilty they will give him
between 15 and 17 years if he's charged
from 10 to 20. well we'll wait and see I
might end up back on the call here
depending on what happens uh we might
have another video chat to do because uh
you never know he might get out we we
just don't know what happens next
yes thanks for your time Don I really
appreciate it mate and uh also well done
on all the charity work uh rescuing dogs
I know you've literally just uh re-homed
the dog today yeah yeah yeah man I'm
happy but I'm sad man it's like I give
away my own child now because he was at
my place he was at my place five days
now but this is the sad part of this
Mission when you find a family and you
get attached it's very hard
well well done mate and um I'll make
sure to put a link in the description
for everybody who wants to check out
your YouTube your charity your Instagram
and thanks again for your time and well
done on reforming and being a good
member of society you're doing some
great stuff for me
cheers thank you very much and once
again sorry for mine I didn't find my
work so good in English but
oh good man oh good I'll catch you soon
cheers buddy thanks a lot okay that was
a very interesting chat with Dan from
Romania uh giving us some information
there uh let us know what you thought of
it in the comments below do you agree
disagree and don't forget to hit that
like button and for more stay subscribed
to the true Jordan YouTube channel and
I'll see you later